so 2020 has been an absolutely in saying
year we're living through a global
pandemic and economic downturn and even
as there appeared to be light at the end
of the tunnel it seems that we could be
going back into a lockdown and and
continue to experience disruption in our
businesses and brands but this show is
not about bad news this is about how you
can pivot your plan and really maximize
some of the trends that are happening
with social media ecommerce so that you
can protect your family provide for your
community your church and really make a
difference and still impact people so
this is the coffee with candle show
buckle up because we've got a lot to get
into today and five specific trends that
you need to know and so if you're fired
up hit the like button for this meeting
my name is Sean kennel and my passion is
helping you build your influence with
online video and social media and I run
a team called think media here in Las
Vegas we have about 12 of us that are on
a mission to help you absolutely crush
it and figure out how to pivot your plan
right now I'm the author of YouTube
secrets and here's the deal you got two
choices like I really think I don't know
if you've been around people that are
you know kind of freaking out right now
or they're like what's gonna happen and
not even a make light and I'm not making
light of any situation you know we're
living through the greatest mental
health crisis that the world has ever
seen a lot of specialists are saying
that it makes sense because now we've
been locked down like we're fighting
about wearing masks were like freaked
out about we're in an election year here
in the US you want to talk about being
on edge I don't know about you we've got
a culture crisis and we've got people
fighting for justice so we've got riots
and we've got peaceful protests and
there's so much going on you got two
choices choice number one you could
panic and complain if you want to join
the majority that's what the majority of
people are doing panicking and
complaining or choice number two you can
prepare and
pivot how you gonna pivot how you know
adapt we're really living in an adapter
die world right now how are you gonna
adapt how you gonna pivot how are you
gonna rethink your strategy your game
plan this show is the coffee with candle
show and in a second we are gonna bring
on some guests we do QA as we would to
help you with your specific business
brand social media channels but in the
first 5 to 10 minutes of the show we get
into some actual content so let me know
where you're watching from let me know
which group you're in are you panicked
right now that's okay you complaining
just like oh man is this gonna get worse
oh let's cancel 20 20 oh man let's I
can't wait till this is over or maybe
this is an opportunity to grow an
empathy to learn to grow a business
because lik whenever things are
shrinking something else is growing come
on what are you up to let me know where
you're watching from and let me know
what you're sipping on I'm sipping on a
little bit of coffee here we got Becca
in the house good to see ya we got
Bianca in the house grateful that you're
here good to see grow with guitar we see
growth guitars hustlin
we got naimans plankin remember the
plank we're doing internet challenges
you know we got Florida in the house San
Antonio what's up Yorktown va what's up
wood weren't burning warrior all right
hey I got five things for you and then
we'll get into some Q&A on the show
today hey five trends that you need to
know so that you can pivot right now
we're not gonna complain we're not gonna
panic we're gonna pivot number one more
than half the world's total population
uses social media what yeah more than
half the world's total population uses
social media right now this article
digital reports 2020 in partnership with
HootSuite revealed that 4.5 billion
people now use the Internet and social
media users the past the 3.8 billion
mark nearly 60 percent of the world's
population is online and that by half of
the year by halfway through this year
2020 that the total world's population
would use social media by the middle
the year wow that's crazy and we're at
the middle of the year welcome to the
halfway point in fact at the time of
recording this July 2nd that is actually
the halfway point of the year you can
look it up in Cora I already did and so
we're right at the halfway point we're
right at the 50-yard line we're in the
locker room right now this is the locker
room conversation you might feel like
you've been beat up by 2020 are already
you might feel like you're down by 7
points 20 points 50 points let's get in
the locker room you're here in coffee
with Cannell to think about how you're
gonna pivot your strategy and listen
half of the world's population is on
social media now I know if you're part
of this show you're already I'm
preaching to the choir you're taking
social media serious but are you taking
social media seriously enough to many
churches businesses nonprofits personal
brands offered they just social media
was like an afterthought yo if you get
locked down not just in the next couple
months but in the next two years when
another pandemic happens god forbid are
you prepared
do you have online influence one out of
two people are on social media friend so
if you got a brand you got a business
you got a message you need to be
leveraging social media but not just in
some kind of mediocre way people say man
there's so much competition how do I
stand out how do I get noticed well good
question
this is the skill to master this isn't
some the world's not going backwards
we're the future is forward you got a
master social media one out of two
people are on social media right now at
the halfway point of 2020 what is your
social media game plan how are you
sharpening your skills leveling up your
strategy pivoting your plan to use
social here's the second trend social
media content consumption is surging did
you know that especially during the real
lockdown I know it's like softening
phase 1 to 15 at different states in
different places that more people are
consuming content than ever before and
and regardless of the pandemic content
consumption goes up every year anyways
like people are getting more used to
more a custom different age groups are
getting more accustomed now I read this
article that there has been an uptick in
US adults social media unit usage it
said it's going to normalize
post pandemic but there's two questions
I got for you
what's post pandemic probably not ending
right like I can't imagine what's gonna
happen that a will end where this is
still gonna be happening in November
2020 and even as it levels out you still
got to be there
Melissa to this depending on your source
51 percent of US adults are using social
media at higher rates it's this is
massive why do I say this cuz I'm here
on the show to help you succeed we're
pushing for your results we're pushing
to help you grow your stuff you gotta be
hustling right now and I get it it's
hard to get over it's hard to get the
motivation it's hard to capture the
vision it's hard to deal with the
emotions of everything that's going on
but what other option do you have what
are you fighting for
man you got a fight you know I got a
baby on the way let's raise a baby
during the pandemic Sean Bradley kennels
come in September 2020 and I'm pumped
but I'm also like dang I got a fight man
I'm not I'm not taking this is not a
joke to me like I get up every day and I
grind cuz I'm fighting for my family man
I'm fighting for my future I'm fighting
for my church like what are you fighting
for drop that in the comments you're
watching the replay drop it in the
comments I'm fighting for my wife man
I'm fighting for my son what are you
fighting for so during these times of
intensity I'm just showing off my my
wife Sonya here in in prego mode you
want to see a ridiculous picture look at
this it's wait for this one yeah yeah
that's that is a a small dog front
backpack on my wife as she enters the
third trimester Sonya can all my friends
that's that is that is her follower on
instagram at Sonya channel yeah do not
what are you fighting for so I'm talking
like this is not peacetime this is time
to grind this is time to get focus get
your mind right your strategy right your
hustle on and really think about the
fact that not only even if social media
usage normalizes for adults by the way
Gen Z's going crazy you're trying to
reach young people or you
a hipster Zoomer talking coming from a
Boomer haha you got it you got to really
figure out right now how can you
maximize the fact that social media
content consumption is surging and I
want to encourage you create more than
you consume so many people are consuming
right now and they're consuming the
wrong stuff dog consume in the news over
and over just like it's like an IV drip
of paranoia agendas negativity now I
watch the news man I stay informed
Google News read the news these are news
articles should I be careful man are you
consuming more than you're creating if
you want to create the future then that
you want better start creating content
to shape your future can't consume
constantly all day long and just let
that stuff make you all toxic paranoid
jacked up panicking complaining come on
we got a pivot and we got to prepare for
the future all right number three some
industries are suffering and some
industries are growing now this is where
it gets real we just got done with a
thick media mastermind small group of
people talking specifically for two days
on their businesses you know tweaking
their businesses how are they pivoting
what are they doing next like really
reviewing their YouTube channels really
putting together strategies breaking
down the behind the scenes of how we do
the real ninja stuff that we do at think
media and and we were talking a lot
about about well yes some industries are
suffering like there's people in our
community like they have restaurants
they've had to shut the restaurant down
there in travel they've had to adjust
their travel business and that's awful
but you can worry and complain all day
long about the industries that are
shrinking and suffering or you could
pivot your plan into something that is
growing like yeah food is really tough
right now restaurants are tough but grub
hug at Brook grub hub post mates and
uber eats going up and it kind of sucks
too because like I really feel I have
empathy for the fact that like the
margins get really messed up when uber
takes their cut and by the time like you
make the thing in like restaurant
capacity like there we have problems but
entrepreneur solve problems like
that's what we do here on coffee with
candle is we don't complain we don't
panic we solve problems and business is
about service it's about value it's
about solving problems so if you can see
where people need service right now then
you can get in a growing industry if you
can see where people got problems right
now and you help them solve those
problems well then you can protect your
family if you can pivot your plan and
see how you can add value right now then
you can actually not just survive but
thrive right now so you might have seen
this Noah Kagan post this is just one
example there's a lot of industries that
are thriving in a lot of different
industry in a lot of different niches
but listen to this five professions that
are on the rise in 2020 based on Google
search dater data
tik-tok editor so you want to work from
home you get lockdown lockdown happens
again you're editing tick-tock you're
getting paid online dog trainer Heather
tourists on the think media team has
been doing digital advertising for a
dentist right now and for a dog trainer
dog trainer that she's been doing
Facebook ads and Instagram ads for just
got more business in June than they have
in the whole beginning of the year
because they learn a new skill because
they partnered with the right person
because they sharpen the saw because
they leveled up because they pivoted to
marketing online they didn't understand
social media so they got help they
didn't understand how to do Instagram
ads so they got help before they figured
it out interestingly enough Instagram
marketers on here number two online dog
trainer 180 percent Instagram marketer
one hundred fifty five percent
Squarespace designer designing websites
for people 129 percent podcast editor is
up ninety-one percent so people are
searching to hire these people this is
Google search that wants these that
wants help with these particular skill
sets so my question to you is what are
you doing now to pivot and prepare for
the future people get mad when I use the
term recession proof I think you can be
recession proof I think you can be anti
fragile unbreakable
and does that mean that your business
never changes no of course it changes it
is a continuous evolution with trends
that are happening things that are
happening my friend I had the fortunate
blessing of living through the 2008 and
9 recession with my wife and getting
crushed like decimated Shawn that was a
blessing yeah it's my perspective it's
all about your perspective how do you
see things why was it a blessing because
sometimes you win and sometimes you
learn and I learned so much and it lit a
fire in me that I said never again I've
been preparing for the past decade I've
been preparing my wife and I've been
preparing think media and I've been
preparing for five years we're
constantly preparing looking ahead
vision earring so things we're doing
really well right now
easy for you well yeah okay grumble all
right oh you want but like pivot your
plan like gets good help pivot your
industry learn a new skill well Shawn I
like it's easy for you say making money
cuz you like you do e-commerce and you
do affiliate marketing and we'll learn
how to do it if you want it like you
want to make more money learn a new
skill like go and roll in college become
a lawyer or a doctor pay a couple
hundred thousand dollars to learn those
skills and you'll get paid more money or
learn how to be a podcast editor learn
how to be a tick-tock editor learn how
to be an Instagram marketer build your
YouTube channel well my niche on my
YouTube channels not do I'm sorry I
really am but if your industry shrinking
change in districts you can't have like
the typewriter companies just being like
this computer thing semester our thing
up man can't believe it well let's ride
this out and let's see if typewriters
come back the things changed
you had to pivot into computers it sucks
my wife and I are big fans of books we
just watch this documentary right now
last night about rare booksellers and
who's super fascinating and where that
we collect books got over like 2000
books I mean I just get like business
book she's in it like really nice like
cool
and it was one of those things where
again I we could complain all day long
and a lot of people were just like other
internet messed up the industry messed
up the rare book industry man now people
can go just get there as many first
editions as they want just get them
right and they've soared them right to
their house and now the bookstore and
and and I get it like you could get mad
at me
for staying what's obvious but like we
could either complain and panic or we
can prepare and pivot and so you got to
pivot your plan man we're gonna get any
Q&A in just a second and start building
some stuff but but these are just some
of the industries that are growing what
industries are growing what industries
can use happen to some industries are
growing some industries are suffering
pivot your plan pivot your niche pivot
your channel your family can be
protected you could grow right now you
could not just survive but thrive
Tony aureole on the team says it's not
about survival it's about thrival I was
like come on thrival hashtag thrival hey
hit like if you're getting value number
for e-commerce is growing e-commerce is
growing e-commerce trends are shifting a
couple different articles it's affecting
retail sales eighty four percent rise
and may retail e-commerce sales will
write worldwide research reveals a lot
of people direct to consumer brands are
having a whole new dtc brands directed
consumer toothpaste directed consumer
wine direct to consumer CBD direct to
consumer whatever so how you playing in
the e-commerce game ecommerce is
becoming commerce and you know you may
have seen CNBC did a like video
journalist kind of article about our
company in about our journey we
generated forty thousand dollars in
april and sales on amazon it's actually
gone up since then well why cuz
e-commerce because people were freaking
lock down so they're shopping online and
that's just amazon i don't know if
you've started watching gary these new
show
called coffee and commerce and I think
they launched a new division of
vaynermedia called Vayner commerce he
acquired a company and they're focusing
all on e-commerce highly recommended
show and this is not just like the
pandemic is agitating this but this is
really more so where things are going
regardless people are now becoming
comfortable shopping online one of the
studies revealed that because of being
locked down some people bought things
like toothpaste online for the first
time but that trends were showing that
they weren't gonna stop even once the
lockdown softened a shift to e-commerce
how you playing in affiliate marketing
right now how you playing on e-commerce
right now whether that's affiliate
marketing is the best way to get started
and this episode is brought to you by
the way by the by the think marketing
podcast and I'll put a link on the
YouTube stream of this coffee with
Cannell and we'll drop it in the
facebook chat Alena will drop it you got
to check out the last two episodes of
the think marketing podcast where I talk
about how you could tap into affiliate
marketing without which is e-commerce
without your own product and start
generating I think you could generate a
couple hundred dollars in the next 60
days a month you just follow the steps
and the think marketing podcast is a
weekly show that comes out on all the
platforms every Tuesday stay connected
because you got to leverage this
ecommerce stuff number five and then we
do some Q&A in just a second hit like if
you're pivoting your plan and you're
choosing not to panic right now digital
advertising is on sale digital
advertising is on sale what's up Katie
so interestingly enough this was not
where this data that I wanted to share
with you came from but this is
interesting to Facebook ad costs are
tanking because of a lot of brands that
have been boycotting Facebook so there
actually are trends that happen like
this this is real-time at the time of
recording this because some big brands
are boycotting Facebook that's a good
thing
because when people pull their money out
of Facebook there's massive opportunity
for digital advertising
Facebook Conan's Instagram so when I say
like Facebook advertising I'm talking
about Facebook and Instagram and and
then of course YouTube advertising
Google AdWords and things like that the
trend is these are advertising is on
sale now let me ask you this what is
your favorite brand or favorite store
that if they have a sale you go crazy
is it like some Dick's Sporting Goods is
it is it is it a Bass Pro Shop gentlemen
or ladies is that is that if your
favorite clothing store has a sale
come on Cyber Monday you know what's
your favorite what sale gets you to pull
out your credit card let me know you
know for me if I'm watching something
and then I find that it goes on sale
right you get that email you're like oh
shoot now I'm gonna go do it you know
I've been watching it I've been thinking
about that thing they're retargeting you
on the Internet
should I guys full price but they're
like Oh 50% off sale and you're like
okay now I'm gonna jump in I'm gonna buy
it well a lot of us myself included when
a sale happens you know we're buying
stuff things we don't need you know to
impress people that we don't like with
money we don't have you've ever heard
that before
you know like it is just stuff digital
advertising has been on sale why well as
soon as the lockdown really happened
back in March 20 20 March May June June
May well how do the months work January
February March April March and April
especially and then May June everyone
freaked out so but advertising budgets
froze advertising froze and so people
pulled their ads down or pause their ads
well so this is the two mentalities my
friends you've got offense and defense
and so a lot of people started playing
defense they started just trying to
protect and hunker down and say let's
just ride this thing out man those
people are gonna get crushed many
already have been you got to be you got
to be pivoting your plan you got to be
leaning in you got to be leaning in
intentionally you got to be leaning in
with wisdom but you got to lean in
and pivot your plan so digital
advertising is on sale and that means
that you can if one other two people are
on social media you can get in front of
your ideal audience your target customer
you can get in front of your target
person that you want to reach and so
summarize these trends my friends social
media one out of two people was on
social people are on e-commerce is
growing digital advertising is on sale
you know like you got to be leaning in
and learning YouTube live streaming
digital advertising online business and
this is not a time where it's gonna be
easy right to pivot I'm not saying this
gonna be easy it can be hard but it's
gonna be worth it and I my heart for you
is that your family's protected your
business is protected that you can maybe
pivot industry some industries are
shrinking some are growing that you can
pivot your plan and that you can have a
bright future not just survive during
this pandemic but thrive during this
pandemic and beyond because you see
where things are going now's the time to
prepare
not now's the time to pivot if you look
at this even though social media online
online display and search are still up
the yellow here is global advertising
investment classifieds TV radio all of
that's tanking you can see that's been
going down post outbreak but here's what
happened is 20%
even in like social media advertising is
drop 29.8% already cut in half so even
though people are still spending in
those verticals there is massive
opportunity with them still now you got
a no trends and times and seasons high
levels of spending during the
presidential campaign are about to
really start happening and already kind
of are because here in the u.s. we're in
an election year so there's gonna be a
lot of money pouring into campaigns
I heard to the tune of 1 billion dollars
will be spent on advertising for the for
Donald Trump's re-election campaign I
don't know what I heard that at a coffe
when I heard his marketing manager speak
so I don't know what Joe Biden's gonna
spend but it's gonna be a lot of money
so you got to uh there's there's maybe a
window even right now for you to really
really learn it lean in and pivot your
plan hey what are you doing to pivot
your plan let me know in the comments
today question of the day how are you
pivoting industries how are you using
e-commerce how are you what are you
focusing on in social media
are you doubling down on social media
right now shout me out in the Facebook
comments or in the YouTube comments on
the coffee with Cannell show and today's
episode is brought to you by the think
marketing podcast make sure to subscribe
on Spotify iTunes on Google and wherever
you listen to podcasts and check out the
last two episodes and all the episodes
in fact you've got a this is what we're
here for this podcast is to help you
pivot your plan this podcast will help
you learn and rethink your business
rethink your YouTube channel rethink
your strategy rethink your approach
because our heart for you is to not just
survive this crazy time in the world but
thrive during it hey on this show I
bring you on the show to answer your
question so the team is dropping the
link for you to join a couple different
places and so you just click that link
if you come on make sure you got good
audio good internet good Wi-Fi all the
things so that we can connect and we got
Tim on the show yep where are you on
screaming from and what's your business
I'm from Clearwater Florida and we have
a couple channels that were running I'm
engaged to a Filipina so we do a lot of
Filipino American content and then I
finally talked her into a beauty fashion
channel because of what you were talking
about with the affiliate linking and
that kind of piqued my interest and she
kind of won the the life lottery you
know she did she came out beautiful so
it kind of helps a lot
so that is where we're focusing right
now that's awesome what's the channel
called her channel is called Joy's
joyful world and the other channel is
tea soy and morena
joyful world Joy's joyful world and I
think we need to change that name
because there's a lot of a lot of worlds
out there six videos out yes yeah yeah
cool how can I help today well so we are
posting you know new new videos for
unboxing you know different beauty
channel Beauty content beauty products I
should say you know and she's trying to
come up with ideas for four different
trying to anticipate the the wands in
the need you know you see a lot of a lot
of people doing fashion channels and
they are they're getting millions
millions of views but the question is
like how do you anticipate what people
are actually looking for because by the
time it already comes out maybe not
already shifted that's a good question
you know um a couple strategies that I
would do specifically for her is one you
don't need to worry about the fact that
someone's getting millions of views
because there's a long tail in YouTube
meaning of course there's gonna be like
I've this is clearly obvious in tech so
think media has a lot of channel
authority we have subscribers already so
if we can release a video about the new
Sony zv1 we can get a lot of views on it
but it doesn't mean other people can't
get views I think about Diana who's a
part of our community she helps us out
on the thick media team she's got a
channel that has six thousand five
hundred subscribers and she just did
some stuff about the cb1 she's gained
hundreds of views as well she may not
get as many as we do with the
subscribers or with the channel
Authority or even with the timing but
there's a long tail of viewership so I
want to encourage you and everybody
listening don't look at the competition
and say up they've already covered that
you may only be able to get 1% you know
of the viewership of the interest if
there's other big dominant players but
you got a rock that 1% that 1% is
actually massive opportunity because a
lot of people just sit and they don't
post so jump on things and jump on
things quick specifically I think you
got to be really intentional and
specific with your video ideas so for
example so excited what's in my Ipsy bag
is a decent title or video but my
thought is I don't know if it's he has
so maybe she went to Ipsy and bought
stuff I guess I'm thinking more no ok I
thought it was like a month monthly
subscriber um you know deal so that's
that video in my opinion is not specific
enough because you know and it still
actually did good but I would do like
very specific as soon as you get the tip
see July 2020 which at the time of
recording it's like the first two days
in July you know so I see what you might
actually I miss this person not even
showing their subscribers or I'm a vid
IQ working for some reason so you know
couple channels I mean they're getting
18 thousand views two thousand views one
point because people want to see that
newest July so does that make sense like
more specific every single title here my
daily routine is shiny straight here day
that's not specific enough
I finally got my glam bag okay well I
guess it says June but like June's not
even in the thing and when we do if see
June like people want to see the
spoilers they want to see the glam bag
plus they want to see an unboxing of it
and that could be so much more specific
specific even this what I got in my
Amazon skincare haul kind of good but is
there like an Amazon is it monthly
so that stuff that she actually ordered
because she purchased it on purpose okay
good and then on top of that so I mean
it by the way do this video because this
is cool 61 people in your in her
community liked it they clicked like but
then also dive directly in to the Aztec
secret Indian healing clay and notice
that all of these can be like revenue
with water before and after like very
specific product review videos and I
know it takes energy I know it takes
hustle but what I would also be thinking
to whatever degree she could sustain
this I wouldn't I wouldn't upload one
video a week or two videos a week I
would make this video and then I would
make specific videos about each of these
products because that's where the magic
would happen I'd be like Aztec Indian
secret Indian clay versus bentonite and
I'd get the bentonite ordered up and I'd
make this video and grab the 94 thousand
views or the 152 thousand views off of
that plus those searching for that exact
specific product this is right on
today's theme because those searching
for that exact product are probably
about to make a buying decision and so
they're literally imagine right they're
like okay it should I get the Aztec or
should I get the bentonite and they're
like okay great she explained like I had
the same skin tone as her like okay I'm
in let me get the Aztec stuff she's like
yeah there's links in the description
below BAM she's on e-commerce affiliate
marketing is rolling in that video can
be much more searched because it's much
more specific and I know it takes hustle
and work but like I would be banging
these videos out because every time you
upload a video gives you another chance
to rank to get discovered because even
in the meantime by the way it looks like
you guys are doing great I mean got 150
subscribers one of the videos got 250
views so then it's 250 views then it's
500 but then one gets 5,000 and it
starts to ramp up and I would just be
taking massive action on that specific
strategy especially tweaking some of
those titles okay sounds good that makes
sense it does and I'm super inspired by
a one of your to one of your training
sessions it said to put in timestamps on
your videos so I tried that on this one
as well as the affiliate linking so I
appreciate that awesome I love it man
hey I appreciate you as well Tim and
thanks so much for being here a little
tip on that I if you're going to do
these timestamps drop them in the top
pin comment as well
you can say all the products are in the
description here's timestamps for the
video and you could then put those it's
helpful for people and it helps them
navigate it could backfire I mean isn't
really backfire but the backfire is like
people might be you know they might not
watch the whole thing they'll skip
straight to 3:40 you know three but it
actually won't really backfire because
people jump anyways if they go uh it's
kind of boring
I don't know suggesting videos so I
would much rather give the viewer what
they want and develop that goodwill with
the viewer so that they want to keep
coming back and see how highly organized
and helpful the content is so just a
thought
you give you already did them since you
did them you wrote them out they look
great in comment as well is a second
place to do the timestamps and those
will also be clickable the same way cool
thanks bro hey appreciate you Tim thanks
much for coming on thank you hey this is
the coffee with candles show we're
helping you get your mind right your
hustle on your grind fixed your rising
grind
blend perfectly balanced what kind of
coffee are you sipping on today you got
the tea going water going what's
happening let me know I'm sippin on some
Pete's coffee from an espresso machine
pod not my favorite
I'll make a little arrow press later
today with some Ethiopia coffee from
best of coffee hit like if you're
getting value when you got strategy or
some tips out of that last one and we're
going to keep the grind going today we
got Oliver coming on the show what's up
Oliver where are you from what do you do
hey Sean can you hear me I can oh great
I'm streaming actually from Helsinki
Finland Oh awesome Helsinki you know my
step dad Phil s : is traces his roots
back to Helsinki Finland oh yeah okay
that's really cool first of all it's
it's a real honour to actually be here
and ply with you Sean today I've been
following you guys for years now and I'm
just super super grateful for all the
all the work you do with the team you've
helped me get really really far with
YouTube
I appreciate that Oliver what's your
channel let me look it up while you're
telling me what you do
sure sure actually this is one of the
seelye things about my channel it's
really actually hard to find with just a
name but if you it's the name of the
channel is just Oliver with double our
but if you if you just look up all the
University on on YouTube I should come
up quite quickly in the results
Ollie University Alto 800 so double alt
o Aalto University yeah driver's sorry
17,000 subscribers no should be if you
actually bring oh sorry just go to the
search results this one right here
all over are got it yeah so but what I
what I'm doing I basically make videos
for international students who are
looking looking at Finland as
opportunity or a choice for them to do
our university degree and I try to
tackle different topics that they are
wondering during application and then
after actually relocating to Finland and
I've been doing this for officially for
a couple of years now really started
grinding a year ago and it's actually
been really really great because I I
work in marketing and I am actually
furloughed at the moment because of the
current crisis and I've actually been
able to get enough revenue from the
channel to not only make for my day job
salary but I I've been actually doing
better in terms of salary compared to my
day job we just asked how do you make
money from the channel oh yeah that's a
good question so I actually I'm
currently relying fully on brand
corporation so I have a couple of brands
working with me and and actually that is
something that I've had a huge amount of
luck with because both of them are
nonprofits sure they're public so other
university is one because
we're still doing my masters there and
then then another is a a housing
provider for finished students or
students in Finland and when I when I
when the current crisis hit I actually
thought that them all the different
brands are going to cut their marketing
I was furloughed from my company right
and I reached out to them immediately
and asked hey what's the situation and
I'd really really like to continue
working on these especially now that I
don't have a job for a couple of months
and they said that sure this current
crisis it doesn't hit our marketing
budget let's let's continue working on
and I I'm actually about the go
full-time because I'm doing enough money
to start pursuing this as a career
which is really really awesome
congratulations man I think Oliver your
story is not just inspiring for me but
for the whole community here and what an
awesome example of just the modern
landscape that we're living in you're a
student finishing your master's degree
that you're about to go full-time you
don't have to do another job
correct you were able to do this with
two thousand two hundred and ninety
subscribers you are able to make that
money from a couple of different brand
partnerships because you picked a
specific niche it looks like you served
that niche very well it looks like
you've learned powerful skills because
you got crispy photography crispy
thumbnails great video content you've
you understand that video production
includes the paid promotion so we see
that and you're helping people with all
this practical stuff regarding a very
specific niche I just want people to
hear all that and think about man how
are you pivoting your plan think media
community how are you how are you you
know rising and you know of course some
your brand's could have been disrupted
they could have been that gap marketing
dollars are cut but even in the midst of
this you've got online income right you
make these videos from home I'm actually
working from another office currently
yeah the campus is completely locked
down still so I'm actually working work
from off-site but yeah I started from
home then moved to another location and
now I'm just trying to invest in more
you read the eyes
sorry do you rent the office or are you
able to use it I'm actually Cole renting
with I we have another business work
that we're working on with a couple of
friends so so there's a god and that
empirically double using loko space okay
cool well hey how can I help today
what's your question yeah actually my
question is is about the marketing or
the the brand deals so what I noticed
what I did one of the biggest mistakes
that I made in the beginning was that I
did not take YouTube or the channel
seriously because of the number of
subscribers and an abuse and so on
I'm sure that many people have had the
same problem and when I actually signed
the first deal which was almost a year
ago when I had what a thousand
subscribers I completely understood
myself and I priced myself really badly
because the idea was that or or the way
I pitched it was basically that I'm
doing this as a hobby as a side hustle
and I'd like to get some money in order
to invest in better cameras etc and now
that I noticed during the current crisis
that okay this should be more I really
need to get more revenue out of this if
if I want to go full-time but how can I
actually raise my prices when I've
already under priced myself so badly and
the question is how do you actually
price yourself in the beginning when
your value is not maybe that much as
high as you would think of it being if
you yeah that's good question
so how did you do a contract how long's
the contract form the contract was
actually for a year I've now redone all
of them I can get back to this but I
just want to get your answer before
great
so I mean a couple things to to consider
one
I think that if you've already locked it
in what it is now I would think of a
compelling pitch to raise raise it but
you need to think through a couple
things so if you could say you're
getting more viewership now and prove
that are you tracking results
click-through rate signups how are you
tracking that stuff we actually again
this is my background in digital
marketing we just actually the second
that we signed the contracts we also set
up UTM jet tags - all of the links that
I have in my videos and I've been
routinely sending emails to both
partners about results and trying to ask
them being as proactive as possible
trying to also saying that or managing
the expectations on I'm saying that ok
sure the viewership is small currently
but if if and when results come in I'd
really like to know immediately so that
we can correct the make corrections if
need be yeah one of the the most
powerful goals which are already working
on would be to prove you know ROI
reprove return on investment we were you
know talking to because of even having
Amazon affiliates and that's massive for
us we got big numbers Amazon affiliates
we can go into like our Amazon affiliate
backend and actually see the results so
I want you to you know find a way to
maybe encourage them to do a dashboard I
don't know if it's a promo code or if
you use a link shortener at least you
could track how many links are being
sent when they click the link in the
description you got to find a way to
track but even if we look at like
yesterday on Amazon affiliate for us we
did one thousand one hundred and seventy
nine dollars in profit on you know our
brands we can go to photo and cameras
and see that ok 3m 50s were sold here
eight knee were 660 LED lights were sold
here 160 mark - a couple more em 50s
different kits we will then pull reports
and say hey brand here's the results
we're gettin so the end of the day of
horse sometimes if you want to negotiate
and position yourself you may not want
to shine as much light on results but if
possible that's the ultimate goal
because if you can create more leverage
by saying look man I'm getting you
results I'm this is happening so that's
the thing one thing too though is your
pitch should amplify quality which I'm
sure you're already doing it's not about
the amount you could work with a lot of
other YouTube creators but my channel so
specifically solves this problem for the
exact the exact target audience for this
hether Taurus on her home school Channel
which is a not a massive Channel has the
same thing she's like well they're all
home school moms like this is not a
blended audience this is like a very
focused audience so when she worked with
a curriculum company she was able to tie
in that pitch to how quality and aligned
the audience was and then you know I
think you can always reach out for the
increase you know try to maybe talk
negotiate put a proposal together but if
they say no I mean you could potentially
add more brand sponsors find other ways
to generate revenue and the biggest
thing would be to get more influence as
your influence grows influence comes
first
income comes second I know you know that
but like as you grow the channel more
and maybe ask them if they were to deny
an increase in rate say well what would
have to happen for for us to hit that
target or whatnot and it depends on of
course your relationship with them but
I've learned that for us we've been in
relationships it sounds like it's just
such so much synergy there you're a
student at the University like all kinds
of stuffs happening like what would have
to happen is so sometimes we'll talk
I'll talk to brand reps from companies
and it'll be like yeah if you can't do
that now could you do it later
how can you one other tip would be
bundle things like is there any way to
bundle your offerings this is really
good for just general anybody that's
aspiring to kind of be an influencer or
a lifestyle entrepreneur or build a
personal brand if you have influence on
other platforms or if you're building an
email list
if you have any other digital marketing
edge or collaborations or partnerships
that you could do could you bundle that
and offer them something else like one
idea is coming to me now I don't know if
you want to add a new content format to
your channel but what if you interviewed
professors what if you interviewed
academic authors what if you interviewed
people like let's just say it was super
relevant and those interviews would
attract students that wanted to be a
part of the school and a new show was
brought to you by Aalto University or
whatever it is and you pitch them that
new show and that new shows gonna cost
twenty thousand dollars and you're also
inviting them to bankroll production of
it a little bit because there's gonna be
some special features to it a lot of
what I'm kind of trying to throw out at
you is kind of just biz dat biz dev
business development kind of thinking
creative and pitching and communicating
and seeing what happens and I know
usually just means not yet because it
just means what needs to happen next to
get positioned because if you can drive
the results for them or at least get the
perceived value for them then they they
may want to take action later and any
thoughts there is any of that helpful
let's say let's say let's say it this
way um for anyone who's watching this is
actually the reason why why I love you
guys so much because I've been getting
so much value and basically everything
that you just said has it has already
gone through my mind and many of the
things that you said has has actually
contributed to the fact that I've been
able to grow the relationship with these
these partners and I'm actually able
soon to go in just a just a moment to go
full-time so I would agree with you
hundred and ten percent and I would
really really encourage anyone to apply
the same principles because they really
work and and just especially in building
the relationship with them with a brand
that you either working for already or
and want to work for in the future
Oliver I appreciate that appreciate your
kind words and and you're pretty good a
video production as well
I like you've liked editing now video
production right so I've been doing this
as a hobby for years but I really stuck
my feet into into into it when I started
working or actually we branded and I
built a podcast video podcast for the
company that I'm working for again based
on on on your your gas channel as well
as Joe Rogan's and that really really
gave me a lot of the skills that I'm now
using to build my own channel so
everything that I basically be doing for
the last four or five years in my work
has been contributing into building the
skill sets as you guys got to say so
many times that I actually need in
building this YouTube channel and
everything in the future as well well
awesome hey I appreciate that two quick
questions well one final idea and one
question about your one of your videos
final idea is you also could again
besides pitching maybe a show to sponsor
one of the ways to charge money to
brands is not just because of the
influence but because of the ability to
produce content and creative like what
it would cost them to produce some sort
of a promo or a higher-end video or
something about the school or something
showing off you know you're doing like
gimbal work you've got fancy editing and
they have the ability to use that
creative themself maybe you're in it
maybe or not like pairing together the
ability to create content content has
value in and of itself maybe they want
to put paid ads behind a 60 second 30
second video you create about you know
one of these entities and I'm sure
they've probably worked with other video
production people as well but you
already have a foot in the door and so
beyond getting paid for a brand
partnership on the channel even if it
didn't hit your channel and maybe it
also hits your channel but it's
something very strategic you're already
thinking digital marketing and so you or
angle of pitching is like look man these
other companies yeah they know how to
produce they know how to do video
production but they don't understand
digital marketing like they don't
understand hooking the viewers attention
if this is going to be a Facebook ad or
an Instagram ad in the first few seconds
what I'm proposing is that I will
produce a video for you I'll produce you
know or or rather even propose and these
are some of my packages hey by the way I
just want you to know about a new
offering that I have it's a it's it's
kind of a high-end strategic you know
video production arm of my company if
you're interested to talk more to get
some videos to market this upcoming year
that you could use on your own website
and everywhere else let's talk and you
could charge a premium for the skills
you've been developing and I want to
just say I'm so impressed
and respect that you've been leveling up
your skills because that's what we are
telling people we're saying hey pivot
man you gotta learn new skills um and my
question for you is this sure this is
kind of a new feature and I don't know
if all channels have it but how are you
doing this little section area right
here sure this is actually something
that I noticed that Philip DeFranco was
using exactly just hostile DeFranco talk
about this right right right and he was
really frustrated that YouTube didn't
bring it early enough so if you go to
the description box yeah the thing
actually the the guest that you had
earlier I had just he was missing one
thing but he have to do with the
timestamps is that you have to enter or
input the zero zero zero mark as well so
that YouTube knows where it's where the
video starts okay which sounds a bit
silly but actually that it will actually
to the chapters into the video
automatically got it yeah man those two
my old videos as well but it's really
labor-intensive so yeah I thought so
it's just it's just a timestamp thing so
I just wonder if it just doesn't do it
for everybody or maybe I didn't do the
zero zero zero right I think I've been
actually looking at your your guys
descriptions and I think that you're
missing a zero I didn't do I didn't do
zero zero zero yeah you can actually
tried live if you want to set the zero
zero zero and it should update
immediately coffee with can oh you saw
it here we're learning how to do
chapters and what do you do at the zero
zero so you just type bounce you don't
have to have anything else I think I
just have an intro so that he passed
some
singing the chapter text intro yeah and
then if you say I think it should update
deigning here we go we'll see maybe
maybe it off oh it did Laura whoo yes
copy channel that is that's a sick
feature right there makes it more
convenient people can surround get to
those different parts that they want Wow
hey I appreciate it bro thanks for the
tip forward of course helping each other
yeah yeah well hey there's so much for
coming on the show and being a part of
our community do you love your hustle of
your entrepreneur spirit love how you're
leading and love that you're you're a
game changer man you're in this new era
entrepreneur and you're just getting
started like your future so bright I
gotta wear sunglasses man thanks so much
John I really appreciate first of all
the opportunity to be here and all the
work you guys put in it'sit's amazing
for all creators who are going for
YouTube honestly and on full-time it's
it's it's massive
whatwhat do you guys do thank you so
much Oliver I appreciate you and keep
crushing it will do cm coffee with
candle helping you build your influence
build your business pivot your plan with
social media and online video we just
learned that if you've already doing
timestamps just do a zero zero zero
that'll let YouTube know when the video
starts and you can do chapters I like
this we've done timestamps a lot that
gives data to Google I highly recommend
this video because actually time steps
can help you rank this video is how to
rank YouTube videos on the first page of
Google and there's five tips there about
small tweaks lead the giant Peaks Javier
said love to zero zero zero moment so I
just dropped a link to that video if you
haven't seen it that'll help you get a
lot of traffic we got 1.1 million views
in 2019 from Google search on our
content time codes can help that and
that tweak right there just make the
time codes a little bit sharper and so
and
see those chapters are an absolute game
changer so pumped about that now we got
Scott under on the show today and as
Scott gets ready to introduce himself I
want to remind you today's show is
brought to you by the think marketing
podcast and if you haven't started
listening you can search think marketing
on a pot on Apple Spotify Google here's
my question for Scott have you heard an
episode of the think marketing podcast
yet I'm in VRA so you consume pretty
much everything you guys put out if you
from acidly in the last 18 months sick
bro I appreciate that hey tell me about
what you do what's your channel and
where you from yes a channel wise if you
go youtube.com forward slash unders go
straight to me I live just outside
Liverpool in the UK primarily like my
channel started as I make music and I
would upload and share my music and then
it was how do I get people to listen to
my music just showing people that side
of it and it's just built out into what
it is now and I just carried on that
approach of you know if if you want to
get someone to listen to something
you're doing give them some like the
value up front right yeah I love that
and this is um this like the full album
right here yep so you can just extreme I
see no difference that but in that whole
album up to play there is it being a
very little small for anything like that
yeah I agree I agree that's awesome and
then get a month of Apple music free is
that just hooking people up or is that
also like some kind of an affiliate link
nice so so that there's a bounty from
Apple much like Amazon do and to keep
people on Apple music yep
okay strong strong um and thanks so much
for being a part of our VR a community
and for coming on the show how can I
help today
so my real question is I've just
launched course pretty much doing what I
do on YouTube but the full in depth like
break you down similar to what you do
you do
small bits of how to execute something
on YouTube or grow your influence I do
little music tutorials I've done the
whole thing like start to finish start
with a blank project finish out with a
finish track and you get the project and
everything to go with it and yeah you've
landed on the right place and
effectively how would you go about
driving people towards that so I did a
launch I launched it I do launch email
and our in a bit ago six people are
joined so far that's awesome
but I don't really know how to keep
driving traffic to that apart from
emailing the list yeah I love it okay so
oh I love what you're doing and I'm
excited to listen to some of your music
I actually am a pretty into some EDM and
drum and bass stuff when I run so my
whole playlist is like sub focus and
culture shock and like guys like that
but I'm posting your stuff and what I
would do is a couple things I think yeah
building building the list the question
is how are you building the list what do
you give away that's valuable for free
to even get people on the list the
moment of free sample pack that goes
with some of the free tutorials that are
on youtube so if you watch the tutorial
your wonder follow-on exactly as it is
you can download those sounds and work
with it follow it on step-by-step and so
how do so here's a free guide of what
you're doing this is different though
right yeah so that's a guide to building
your like music profile and things like
Spotify but again similar thing and it's
it's building the email this side of it
okay and then is this where's three
sample this one right here that should
be it and so to get these they give you
their email and then you can talk to
them more yep got it so actually a
couple things is one for you and
everybody watching too if you're if
you're building out and trying to grow
your list really streamline and improve
that process
so this page could be a lot stronger
musicians guide to stardom
like in its it's like accurate you know
I don't know if ours are and and you
don't have to be like this is kind of
maybe even fields internet marketing but
but you know attention creative
entrepreneurs and youtubers afternoon Li
a hundred million like there's more
words here picture of me and I'm not
saying that's even you know necessarily
the best page I'm gonna show you this
one did you see our challenge that we
did know if it was recently probably not
I've been digging in deep since this
whole look at that okay cool
so so we did a seven day challenge and
so you know there was authority on here
of different publications we were in
there was you know what should were
gonna learn there was then the opt-in to
enter your information then there was
like some more details about what you
were gonna learn there's some bullet
points you don't have to take it to this
level anywhere near this but I'm just
saying all of this was like who it's for
how it'll help you all of that was put
there ahead of time you know before
inviting Pete so so like consider that
page and I know this is different than
the free but compared to this like this
could be a lot stronger so it really
comes down to one having what you're
giving away be compelling and you
actually want it to be attractive and
desirable to the person that you can
help with your training later and you
also don't need to worry about repelling
people who aren't interested because it
really is only for that but I give if
they want that that so here's another
way put it is the sample pack highly
desirable is the guide to streaming
highly desirable it could be but like
how could you really speak to that
person so that they know exactly like oh
that's me that's what I want I want to
learn what you know I want to learn how
to grab your map to a great you know to
a great release but like I've
the words you use like the copywriting
like all of that meaning copy like
marketing copy and I'd studied that
maybe a little bit maybe pick up a book
on on copywriting because it can make
your landing pages even your youtube
titles stronger that's kind of thing one
and then thing 2 is also even just the
friction I'm experiencing because I'm
trying to get the free sample pack but
it comes here and I see 10 things you
know and and it's and then I'm like is
it this cuz my eyes go to the left side
of the page first but then it's like
that's well that's not free and so I
think okay you know what I'm saying
where then I my goals and then I have to
still pick it out whereas like another
one we do is to checklist calm and and
make it like one thing the the essence
of what a landing page is is one thing
learn the simple formula for making
money with YouTube videos download this
free blueprint with pro tips on what
you're gonna learn second promise 3rd
promise clear cover name an email and
then you're gonna get some other cool
stuff a second chance to enter your name
and email why should you even trust me
because I've done some stuff I've been
features like whatever so you could
template you could template eyes or like
look at some of what we're doing that's
tube jealous calm that's so that's gonna
help so let's then just break it down
and there's there's a lot of strategies
that we talked about and I could help
you with in the future but to kind of
focus on one what you share in the video
clear and compelling like I'm gonna hook
you up for free you know however you
want to say it but like listen like if
you really actually wanna grab these and
follow along maybe this is not only do
want to give a good reason to do it
really maybe over explain how to do it
you want to make it easy like maybe as
you're talking it shows up and you just
go you can grab the sample pack it's
super easy to do just go to the link in
the description below or go to like you
know like under samples calm and and and
then what you'll see is there'll be a
page there and and maybe if you have
different ones pic though explain how to
do it and even if it's
set up even if you don't make it better
if you explained how to get there just
go there click samples or maybe it's
full screen there's like a click noise
and you make this little ad spot or
visual this stuff is really critical in
online marketing because we want to just
make sure that journey is easy to follow
and clear and then enter your name email
I'll email those to you make sure it's
in your main inbox not junk and and then
you'll be able to follow along with me
in the video and so and then you and
then you may want to tell them and say
and also I'll continue to follow up with
other free trainings as well as you know
as some of our programs or whatever like
completely be transparent about like
what's to come and you know I'm here to
help but have a lot of free content for
you and I also let you know more about
some of our accelerators for building
your you know making great music and
learning how to make tracks faster
easier without friction and so then
making thinking about the journey when
they click through the link and then
thinking about the email marketing
follow up if more people come into that
you know six people picked up the thing
because they were down and to get your
deal if you get more people in and you
get better at being clear about what
they get as they're in that process then
six will be 12 and then 12 will be 200
and and they're probably the final tip
is you're a br a student is then crank
up the frustrating part is you have a
lot of great videos with hundreds and
thousands of views but you don't really
go back and improve that explanation or
those pages on those you can change the
links in the description to make them a
little bit better or if you change the
landing page but then it's about your
future is forward with new videos like
following the you know 7rv are a system
and i don't know if you've been in there
seeing the new foundations we just
released a whole new update with like
the new I've just thought going through
the new ones yeah okay dope so so then
it's new videos with that part in the
videos knowing that your proven sales
process is dialed in and you're just
tweaking that and then it goes to scale
like for one example one of your FL
Studio tutorials it's a million views
with a really clear call to action in
there well then 25,000 people or 50,000
of those people
want to go grab the samples go through
the thing and then it's happening
especially with all the sets you've
built and respect for the diligence and
everything you have set up as far so I
think you're probably a few small tweaks
to get better results in the short term
but then crank up the YouTube videos
that are meeting new people adding value
and then letting people know about how
you can help them at a deeper level that
was super helpful thank you sure super
super helpful for sure man I appreciate
you thanks so much for coming on coffee
with Channel Thank You speaker hey the
coffee with Cannell show hit like what
was your aha moment out of any of the
sessions today like what do you got to
do next look we're action takers at the
thick marketing podcast to think media
brand and we take action Christopher
just shared the link to the think
marketing podcast which today's episode
is brought to you by and we want to help
you not just learn good information but
then you got to take action and so what
are you going to take action on type it
out in the comment section below and I
hit the like button if you've been
getting value out of today's episode hey
I want to appreciate everybody what's up
Jessica Carina David David we do the
show once a week where we drink coffee
or tea or water or Jack Daniels I don't
know what you're drinking and and we
hang out and we answer your questions
about marketing about YouTube about
online video so you can go further
faster go check out next to think
marketing podcast if you're just
catching the replay we talked about five
trends right now over half the world's
on social media social media
consumptions up ecommerce is exploding
industries are shrinking but other
industries are growing and there's a
massive sale in digital advertising
right now if you want to learn more
about those topics and you have not yet
subscribed to the think marketing
podcast every single week myself Heather
tourists the think media team are coming
at you on the apples on the Spotify
on the Google's on the androids and on
the YouTube channel so if you're
watching this on YouTube make sure
you're subscribed and if you got value
today can you do me a favor share this
with somebody and not just anybody you
know not even just on your social media
but think about somebody maybe know a
business owner maybe you know somebody
who's a little bit panicked right now
and I don't blame them and they're
thinking about how they could pivot they
mean the world to me if you shared out
this episode because man we saw some
cool stuff that Tim's doing that
Oliver's doing that Scott's doing it's
time to pivot your plan man you can make
money from home you can build side
income streams of income you can start a
business pivot your business you can
grow a YouTube channel it's not too late
to start social media it's not too late
to start YouTube with the right
strategies with the right hustle with
the right community with the right
psychology getting your mind right man
you can do anything and I know it's hard
right now but we're not going to
complain we're not gonna panic we're
going to prepare and pivot and so I
appreciate you Tim thanks for coming on
and definitely check out the think
marketing podcast for those that were
here in the back office thanks so much
for being here every week we'll get to
as many questions as we can but I've got
to jump into some meetings and some
stuff for the day my name is Sean kennel
and I appreciate you so much I'm
grateful for you stay safe stay on your
grind and go check out the thick
marketing podcast the last couple
episodes were fire they're out now
two-part series on affiliate marketing
that you're not gonna want to miss just
search think marketing on any of the
platforms keep crushing it keep smashing
it and we will talk soon